Okay, let's go to Dante from Florida.
We haven't heard from Dante for a while.
Dante is last time he called in, he was a
Tulsi supporter.
Um, Dante, you still with Tulsi?
Um, I'm actually a Bernie Fan, but I do support
[inaudible] Tophi gabbers Kennedy.
But um, yeah, she's still a pretty progressive
candidate.
I never expected her to win the nomination.
Okay.
I think you're right about that.
Um,
but my question was, so it, do you think that
there's a possibility that Elizabeth Warren,
you the
Dante, you're breaking up, you're Britain,
you've got a bad connection.
I heard.
Is there a possibility that Elizabeth Warren,
you think that Elizabeth Warren would be the
candidate that the establishment fully gets
behind and the 2019 to 2020 Democrats primary
as opposed to who as
opposed to Trump or as opposed to other Democrats?
Are you saying in the primary or what primary
and the primary
will the establishment get by?
I mean, listen, they might have no choice
at a certain point, you know, listen, the,
the democratic establishment is not going
to vote for Trump, so they are going to push
for an establishment candidate in the primary.
It seems to be Biden of my, my, if it's not
Biden, the most establishment seeming people
to me strike me as comma Harrison p Buddha
judge.
Uh, is Warren more establishment than Bernie?
Yes.
I guess if you're going to put everybody,
you know, kind of like on a number line, Warren's
more establishment than Bernie, but ultimately
the establishment is going to have to figure
out how to work with whoever wins the primary
and support them against Trump.
Yeah.
But I was just thinking it'd be this is seeming
more like it'd be Elizabeth Warren than anybody
else because Kamala Harris isn't really going
anywhere.
She's been stuck in the same spot.
Well, you're asking a different question.
You're now talking about who's more likely
to win, but I thought you were asking me who
the establishment would like
that establishment is going to end up support
fully backing because it's not going to be
Joe Biden that doesn't look like he's going
down in the polls and he's losing support
even from establishment donors and establishing
classroom Gideon, all of that.
Listen, there's not going to be that long
of a period.
At a certain point it may become clear that
it's not going to be Biden and there's not
going to be that long between that point and
when the primaries are decided so there's
not going to be that much time for the establishment
to say, oh, we're now shifting this way or
that way.
I think the establishment candidates are Biden,
Harris booted judge in that order.
I agree with what you're saying.
It doesn't look like Harrison booted.
Judge are going anywhere though.
Yeah.
So that's all facing like the, the entire
democratic leadership, the DNC, Nancy fool,
she jumps from one I like, they just going
to sit back and not get, like, try to get
influence over whoever the potential nominee
is.
So it seems like they're going to get behind
whoever their best chance to be Bernie Sanders
that they think would be in it seems like.
Yeah.
I don't know that the established, I think,
I don't know that the establishment would
be thrilled for it to be Warren instead of
Bernie on policy.
They end up in almost identical places.
Warren comes from a slightly more establishment
than Bernie though.
She, I mean B, she's not really committed
to medicare for all.
Uh, they, she would continue the status quo,
our foreign policy.
Um,
I don't know that I'm foreign policy.
Bernie and Warren are very far apart.
What's an issue?
What's a, what's a difference on foreign policy?
Um, she just hasn't really made it a priority.
Bernie Sanders, he made it a priority to get
through that, uh, the vote too.
And US involvement in the war in Yemen.
Elizabeth Warren hasn't really made much of
an effort.
Yeah, but that's, I mean you're, you're talking
around the edges.
That's not evidence that they would be substance
[inaudible].
Yeah, that's a big thing.
That's
some anybody ever had the war powers invoked
in, in the Senate.
So that is a big thing and that's a big difference
between Elizabeth Warren and Bernie Sanders.
Hope their platforms are not anymore foreign
policy.
Different.
Yeah.
Right.
But we'll see what happens.
Dante, always great to hear from you, my friend.
All right.
[inaudible] okay, good to hear from you.
I'm glad.
I'm glad for you to hear from me as well.
All right.
That's it for today.
Sorry to everybody I didn't get to.
We will take a quick break and be back with
plenty more.
Right after this